hey guys i'm ryan right and it was to be
crazy so i got a video sent on our real
rejects facebook site called the
weirdest video you'll ever see
apparently that was the wrong video so i
blame that subscriber we're going to be
checking out the weirdest video you will
ever see
guaranteed apparently that is the
correct one
i don't know i mean shrek is love shrek
is life is kind of it for me and I blame
you you should blame me I do I don't
know what we're about to watch but this
should be the correct one you can yeah
you gonna hey you can okay what is for I
don't know
I don't get one ball hey did you need to
get football hi you know you forgot oh
hey Lynette oh why don't you tip is
stickin up hey jakey Massey oh she's
horrible
hey I what Oh what
really hey hey
Hey
your motto
hold on y'all get to today to go man oh
me oh my [ __ ] you clear nah nah I feel
so much for it what y'all talkin about
[ __ ] do we just watch what um I think
it's about okay if I would not even
trying are we going to take a hypotheses
here I would say that in this world
bloodsuckers exist through like
creatures that form from human beings
like it seems like that these are
creatures that come from a disease that
sort of develops and turns into this
bloodsucker thing like because that
little person with like a little version
of the guy I guess the bloodsuckers are
like the guy came from the girl I
thought like he threw a creature at her
and that caused her to suck and then he
took it off and that was no second the
blood oh I'm so confused it seems like
the bloodsuckers are like monsters that
I don't think they're monsters I mean he
seemed like a very sweet creature well
they're like human leeches leeches I can
speak but he was like timid and shy
it just seemed cute but that doctor was
very abusive he was I don't want that
doctor he was a very abusive doctor
who's mean me what kind of actor does
that and I guess they trained them to
learn how to take on like the
bloodsuckers I think especially had a
tennis racket I was trying to hit them
but she has a horrible aim I know she
was horrible at it and then the
bloodsucker attached and then the doctor
came in and I don't know the llamada
name means exactly but I think it's just
a common BAM
it's just a common name and then he got
rid of it I'm assuming that these
bloodsuckers are actually like monsters
that for him I think it'll like many
human leeches in a way or it's just a
really [ __ ] of it is one of the two I
just know that we can always trust Japan
to come up with some really weird [ __ ]
if this is Japanese it is are you sure
positive
you're sure 100% cuz I get them all
confused I'm half asian and I still get
it confused positive hundred percent
okay well that's my theory on the thing
thanks for telling me that video was out
I was definitely
weirder than the other one if you're new
to the channel you can subscribe to the
real rejects you know what I like about
it it was human beings that did this
video it wasn't like some weird
animation it much creepier I started
getting a little nauseous when he was
squeezing him and white stuff was coming
up I started getting actually a little
nauseous I thought I was gonna stop the
video for a second I rarely get like an
upset stomach but that was like
upsetting my stomach just how disturbing
this all look you're very queasy human
yeah no I'm not I'm not surprised
whatever Alyssa I'm a man Alyssa be
crazy has a channel it's growing really
fast right now you gotta check that [ __ ]
out and see why and since this is such a
popular video why not do a shout out
yeah
Cameron toyour the real rejects I would
like a shout out for my youtube channel
cam the coolness 10 and by the way love
your videos Cameron toyour look at how
awkward his arms look I don't know what
alright noise outside I'm ready to dig
it it's like cool but like you're in the
middle of something that's like your
occupy but you're making effort and
you're taking time to take a picture
well you look young you look young so
I'm gonna be a little bit age
appropriate here but you straight up
look like a pimp
like a real pimp like the kind of pimps
that not like oh you a cool pimp like
you look like a pimp that will one day
have a whole line of hookers and you
will prostitute them out and you will
reap the profits from them having sex
with other people
there are such an inspiration to the
youngins well I'm just trying to give
this guy a good career path to go down I
mean you should check out his channel
cam the coolness Tenma wait kitty kitty
go to his channel
I changed my mind
that is the weirdest video I've ever
seen you keep that up and you will get
good hookers one day